[Music]
if you look up at the night sky you may
think that space is pretty empty right
but check this out
this is a map of some of the debris
that's orbiting earth right now some 10
000 tons of it
as we make more trips into space and
begin deploying fleets of satellites the
challenge of avoiding those leftover
bits of debris is becoming harder and
recently that problem got worse in
november russia tested an anti-satellite
missile that created a cloud of over a
thousand pieces of traceable debris it
caused astronauts on the iss to have to
shelter we were recently informed of a
satellite breakup and need to have you
guys start reviewing the safe haven
procedure this irresponsible act
endangered the satellites of other
nations as space gets busier it's also
getting messier so to try and make it
safer and easier to operate in some are
trying to clean it up we're here to
remove those satellites but how do you
do that how do you clean up the
thousands if not millions of pieces of
trash that we've left orbiting our
planet well i've been on a mission to
find out more so grab a dust pan and
brush let's go
[Music]
now you may be thinking why should i
care about space debris if i'm not in
space but having some 36 500 pieces of
junk bigger than 10 centimeters whizzing
around the planet at thousands of miles
per hour doesn't just create a problem
for astronauts
it can create problems for us down here
too after all we use satellites for
everything from weather to
communications to gps and if they go
down it can create a huge problem those
satellites are constantly having to
maneuver to avoid potential collisions
with orbital debris brian whedon is
director of program planning at secure
world foundation a non-profit think tank
that advises policy makers and industry
on space sustainability majority of the
weather satellites and the satellites we
use to observe the earth and monitor
climate change are located in low earth
orbit and that's some of the most
congested areas that problem is
compounded when pieces of debris smash
into other pieces of debris creating
many more smaller pieces of debris it's
something known as kesler syndrome and
it could mean that in the future there
are fewer safe spaces to operate
satellites over time as debris gets
worse
it may be too risky to operate
satellites in certain orbits and that
may mean we forego some of the benefits
that we currently get today brian also
told me that the cost of avoiding space
debris may mean that some future space
projects never get off the ground so why
has nobody really done anything about
this yet well part of the reason is
until recently nobody had to see most of
the rules around what you can and cannot
do in space come from this 1967 un
treaty which basically says that each
country retains ownership and liability
for anything it sends into space
commercial or private but there's no
real mention of having to clean up
afterwards to fill in the gaps around
managing debris in 2001 the us adopted a
best practice around orbital debris now
with space getting even busier
government agencies like the faa are
working on their regulations and closer
aligning them with that standard
practice we're actually getting close to
the point where we will see
more commercial launches on an annual
basis than what we were accustomed to
seeing over the course of about a decade
in march this year the faa brought in
tighter regulations for commercial
spacecraft like spacex virgin galactic
and blue origin around collisions and
debris generation during takeoff and
re-entry and now it's looking at ways to
make sure that anything that the us
sends up into space can be safely
removed from orbit so the idea which we
hope to be ready to propose in spring of
2022 is to make sure we're not creating
unnecessary debris that would inhibit
future space operations and that we have
means to take care of what is placed
into orbit but creating regulations that
prevent adding more debris only really
solves part of the problem and doesn't
really address what's up there right now
so how do you deal with that
well ideas around how to remove debris
have been floating around for years much
like the debris itself many of them
involve using satellites with nets arms
or even harpoons to grab the debris and
now some of those ideas are starting to
become a reality astroscale is a startup
that plans to deploy satellites that can
dock with pieces of debris to deorbit
them they're currently testing the
satellite in space that they're using to
dock with a fake bit of debris through a
series of separating them docking
against the dockings and undockings we
mature a lot of the key technology
needed to actually capture this space
junk in future right now the company is
testing its elsa d servicer which can
only dock with prepared debris that has
this dinner plate size magnetic plate
installed and it has to be installed on
debris before it becomes debris it's a
small
very lightweight plate that you fit
to future customer satellites that are
going to launch but the company plans on
developing ways to capture debris that
doesn't have that plate installed and
say they'll be running tests for that by
the middle of the decade the european
space agency also has plans it's
commissioned swiss start-up clear space
to de-orbit part of a rocket that has
been orbiting the earth since 2013 using
its clear space 1 satellite but a bit of
perspective here those plans are only
set to remove a handful of pieces of
space debris over the next four years
and that's out of the thousands of
pieces that are up there so even if new
regulations curve the amount of junk
that we're dumping in orbit it could be
years before space gets a little emptier
again
hey thanks for watching if you're
interested in the next generation of
space travel then check out the work by
my colleague micah maydenberg i've left
the link below and as always if you're
interested in the future of how we might
be getting from a to b then don't forget
to subscribe see you soon